When answering the last quiz, i called these points very different letter names.
But when we look at this formula for slope, it's not really clear how d and b,
or c and a are related to one another. I think that one thing that might help us
is if we renamed the coordinates of these points, so that they indicated what
each coordinate actually is . Instead of A,B I'm going to call this coordinate
x1, y1, and this point is going to become x2,y2. Using this new notation, we can
change our formula for slope. I like this form much better. To me it's way more
clear now that this quantity on top is the difference between two y coordinates,
and this one in the denominator is the difference between our two x coordinates.
Now note that the y coordinate of the second point comes first in the numerator,
and the x coordinate, the second point, comes first in the denominator. The
question I have for you now, is, does it matter which point, when I find in the
slope between points I call x1, y1, and which one, I call x2, y2. In other
words, if I switch the position of the ones and twos in this equation for slope,
would I get the same slope as my answer?